they chase and it's gonna bounce of the  Lakers it got numbers the ad once again  he leaks out ever abroad fine jeff of  these are graded passing  dog  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  how does she know to touch pass that to  Anthony Davis down there Jordan  adventure finish by Koosman he  appreciated that  unbelievable dinner there's a son be  Oakleaf LeBron  [Music]  [Applause]  let me pick a roll action with David at  the 5 dive into the cup all point la  pass to LeBron James and Anthony Davis  done the rest that's beautiful man here  comes LeBron looking for his first I  think everybody funny is one of many to  the corner  [Applause]  right there times when you wonder does  he really have tonight  [Applause]  what up it's your boy out of luck coach  you like that content I know you like  that content hit subscribe for more of  it from Bleacher Report